what is this night i mean because it's
been a long journey to this night and
for two people who have grown up
watching you loving you loving you
loving everything you do
now for the world to see you
you want to know what's so interesting
and i've said this to you before it's
not so much about me but it's being able
to stand under these lights between the
two of you
for me is the real change that for me
was all the choices that i made coming
up in the industry the things i didn't
do the things that i chose to do and to
see it all come to fruition not just me
being here but seeing you both here in
this position the way you are that i
don't get here without you we don't get
here without you but there is something
to be said you don't do it for the
accolades you don't do it for the added
girls but there is something to be said
for getting those flowers and feeling it
in the morning i ta almost tackled her
on the red carpet i literally won't but
there has to be
how does that feel fill your heart the
number of young actresses
that sent me flowers
literally
and figuratively that wrote new notes
and said thank you miss ralph
i know what you went through and i
appreciate your journey because i'm
sitting high up here because oh my god
those moments just those that's what hit
me really that just gave me chills
because people may not know how many
young women you mentor how many people
you mentor in this business and what you
mean to them and how much you take your
time to stop and talk to these young
ladies about the pitfalls and how to
negotiate contracts and other things
absolutely it's very important you know
i take my service seriously you know
even you know being vice president of
the la local of sag i take all of that
seriously i want people to get involved
in our industry don't just think it's
all about shining in front of the camera
there's so much work and so many details
that take place behind the camera that
truly affect how it is you survive or
thrive in this industry and right now
i'm thrived you are thriving you better
thrive
you guys you guys are making history
tonight in the nominations because
you're only the second show to ever have
all all the african american lead roles
uh acting roles nominated since 86 from
the cosby show
so tonight once again you are making
history you could make even more history
we could even we could make even more
history but i have to tell you as aaron
kaplan a great producer said to me
shirley ralph that abbott elementary is
literally saving broadcast tv
so we want to save tv we want to collect
as many awards as possible and come back
over the years and do it all again i
love it can you give me the lowdown on
the swavarsky crystals the hair it's art
what's happening my daughter ivy coco
has been styling me along the way and
she said mommy if you're gonna be
unbasically black your hair must be
stella and here i am swarovski crystal
stellar all over my head we're sparkling
from the top to the bottom i will say
this now you better not win because
we'll be in the back crying and
screaming we're going to cut out if you
win if you win things are going to go
crazy oh
thank you
look at this one look at that one i did
her sketch show and met quinta doing the
show go on miss thied yeah come on up
here robin get an intro
guard interviews
we love this magic up here right now
this is black ladies sketch show the
first of its kind i do winning so many
wonderful thank you so much nominated
again yes let's not forget bye
and i'm so happy that the episode i did
with you that's where i met that's right
that's right how much fun was that it
was a viral proposal sketch and you ate
that up okay you ate that up and quinta
was like i have to work with her again
thank you i have to work she fought
tooth and nail and you said yes thank
you
thank you from both of us thank you
anyway good listen all the time thank
you um are you friends with cheryl you
have a great day
that's good thank you you enjoy every
bit of this
i mean come on girl you gotta serve if
you can still serve
[Music]